what's going on people today we're about
to break down episode 27 of attack on
titan season 4 in which falco's draw
titan finally made its first appearance
in this video i'll be explaining the
interesting reason why a shifter looks
like a giant bird as well as the
different ways that this has been
foreshadowed from the first episode of
the season
along the way we'll also be breaking
down kyomi's new plan to stop the
rumbling and why general mcgath made the
sacrifice that he did
before we get into it though this video
is brought to you by rage shadow legends
in case you've been stuck in the past
dimension and haven't heard about this
game raid is a free to play rpg
available on android ios and pc it has
amazing boss battles global player
versus player modes and over 600
champions to choose from one of the
great things about raid is that the
champions come in different shapes and
sizes with each of them belonging to a
specific faction my personal favorites
right now are the dark elves not just
because of their epic designs but also
because of the story behind them 700
years ago they used to just be regular
high elves like this but they were
tented to the dark side for reasons that
surprisingly had nothing to do with
getting evil powers soon after that war
broke out between the two sides and with
champions like this it's easy to see why
peace hasn't really been an option
anyway there's never been a better time
to get started with raid and if you use
the link in my description or scan the
qr code new players will get a free
starter pack worth almost 30 dollars
this includes a free champion called
aina who's a member of the barbarian
faction not to mention you get 200k
silver and an ancient shard that will
give you another champion as soon as you
get in the game
you'll find these rewards here in your
inbox for the next 30 days only so be
sure to click the link in the
description and i'll see you in the game
okay so in the last episode the
alliance's main goal was to get control
of this flying boat and they tried to do
that by taking a peaceful approach where
they wouldn't have to kill any jaegers
unfortunately as things progressed that
plan fell apart completely with flock
then ordering his men to get rid of
armin mikasa and the rest of the
alliance this put the scouts in a
position where they had to start killing
their fellow islanders which culminated
in daz and samuel being murdered by
connie episode 27 begins with daz's
lifeless body descending deeper into the
water and the two scouts take a second
here to reflect on what they just had to
do
connie was one of the people who was
most vocal about not wanting to resort
to violence so to end the lives of two
friends is something that's likely gonna
haunt him regardless of how this ends in
the background we see annie and reina
smacking down some more jaegers and this
continues on for a while and after that
the anime moves down to the basement
where the alliance encounters their next
big obstacle
as we already know the azimubito
mechanics are the only ones who can
prepare the flying bird for takeoff and
in this scene they reveal it would take
them half a day to get it ready by
itself this creates two major problems
with the first being that it's
impossible to defend the flying boat for
that long considering that the enemy can
endlessly send wave after wave of
reinforcements there's no way for this
small group of people to protect the
plane and the mechanics for half a day
the second problem is that even if they
somehow managed to do everything right
it would still be too late to save
liberio in the last episode hanji
confirmed that the rumbling was already
on the marlin continent and in half a
day the times would be able to keep
marching for hundreds of miles this
means that no matter what happens
there's a zero percent chance they'll be
able to stop libero from getting
trampled and this causes jean to flash
back to one of the good times they had
there it's no secret that the scouts
spent months living in mali during the
time skip between seasons three and four
and this memory is from a time when they
got drunk with some refugees who were
living on the continent with liberio
being destroyed he realizes that all the
nice people he met are going to be
trampled which obviously isn't something
he wanted to happen
that being said kiyomi comes up with a
plan that would at least give them hope
of saving innocent people in other
cities and this plan involves preparing
the flying boat somewhere else we've
already established how the situation on
paradise is way too chaotic for them to
do it here but on the continent the
azimuthito have a hangar where the plane
could be serviced in the basement she
shows them a map of mali and based on
the hangar's location it should be
possible for the alliance to get there
pretty quickly
using this ship to get them there the
mechanics would then have time to get
everything ready without waves of
jaegers trying to kill them however
kiyomi's plan does also come with a
massive risk because the place they're
going to is set to be trampled by the
rumbling although they'll be able to
reach the hangar before any titans get
there there's no guarantee the mechanics
will finish preparing the plane before
the rumbling arrives to squash them
either way it's still the best choice
they have right now and so the alliance
sets the plan into motion by telling the
others what's happening in annie's case
her main motivation for stopping the
rumbling was to save her dad at this
stage she has no idea that saving her
hometown is impossible and as a result
she continues to help out by defending
the azmobito in this scene kyomi and the
mechanics exit the basement so they can
run towards the ship while hanji mikasa
and the warriors do everything they can
to keep them alive as the aegiris
continue to fire the armor titan reaches
over to offer some protection but in the
process he exposes himself to direct
attacks from thunderspears up until this
point he and annie had actually done
pretty well to avoid taking damage from
these things but in this current
situation they had no option but to put
their bodies on the line and essentially
become human shields in particular the
female titan gets her arm blown off
trying to save them and then rhino
swoops in to take even more damage
similar to how he saved zeke back in the
first episode
now with all of this going on flock
realizes that the alliance are planning
to escape by ship and he orders the
aegiris to focus on destroying it this
was a great strategy since all it takes
is for one single thunderspear to make
contact and after that there's no way
this thing would be able to set sail
what this means is that kyomi's plan
will fall apart if just one soldier is
able to attack the ship but the female
and armored titans stand strong and do
their best to intercept the different
rockets despite that peak makes the
observation that they won't be able to
hold out long enough for the ship to
leave as the mechanics need around 15 to
30 minutes to get everything in place
the way things are going the warriors
will be blown to pieces before that can
happen and this is when falco decides to
get involved although pique warns him
against it falco felt like he had to do
this because in his mind the only reason
things are going badly is because he's
the one here instead of poco if galiyad
was alive then he would have been
helping annie and rainer rather than
watching him from the sidelines and this
survivor's guild is why falco had the
urge to intervene
instead of immediately chasing after him
pique uses her cut titan to bring the
remaining members of the alliance to the
ship while kony prepares to get back
into the fight having already killed daz
and samuel the only way their deaths are
gonna have any meaning is if the ship
sets sail and they're able to stop the
rumbling if flock and the other jaegers
manage to prevent that then it means
that connie would have killed his
friends for no reason and that's why
he's so determined to make sure his
actions weren't in vain
meanwhile up on the rooftops hanji
notices a train full of reinforcements
heading towards the harbour
on this train are the additional waves
of jaegers that we mentioned earlier and
with the alliance barely holding on as
it is the commander knew they had to
deal with this train as a priority
luckily for them it was blown up out of
nowhere before they had to do anything
and the person responsible was
instructor chadis later in the video
i'll explain exactly why he did this but
for now all we need to know is that he
was inspired to take action after seeing
the scouts working together with annie
speaking of the female titan after
taking one too many thunderspears her
head had now been decapitated not for
the first time while rhino wasn't doing
much better in this state the two
warriors weren't able to move or see
anything respectively making them both
sitting darks as the aegis made a move
to kill them however at the last moment
connie makes a heroic entrance as he
slices down a whole group of enemy
soldiers while mikasa supports him by
taking out the ones who are shooting at
the same time jon chips in by shooting
more jaegers with his rifle and this
moment was brutal because you could tell
the girl he killed was absolutely
terrified
anyway soon after this the card titan
finally joins the battle by breaking
through the rooftop and we get this cool
sequence of her evading about 50
thunderspear attacks
on the ground falco then runs towards
the action having already cut his hand
and this injury serves as the catalyst
for his first ever transformation i
gotta say this shot of his titan
emerging from the lightning was easily
one of the best in the whole episode and
in terms of the design is unlike any
draw time we've ever seen
to start things off falco shifter has
several bird-like features including a
beak made from titan hardening
animalistic hair covering his whole body
feathers on his elbows and hands that
strongly resemble bird cores
in terms of other unique features his
draw also has two sets of teeth with his
inner mouth being similar to that of a
pure titan while his outer jaw is the
one that deals the real damage
now if you've been wondering why exactly
he looks like this the answer is that
it's a direct result of the beast titan
spinal fluid
in the past we've seen how spinal fluid
can allow one shifter to inherit the
characteristics of another with an
example being how aaron ingesting armor
fluid allowed him to gain armor of his
own
when it comes to falco he drank the
beast titan's tainted wine which has now
led his shifter to inherit these animal
traits
users of the beast titan are known to
appear as an animal they have some kind
of connection to and in falco's case
he's had a connection with birds ever
since his introduction
the opening shot of the season was a
bird circling above falco as he told it
to fly away and later in the trenches he
mentions an interesting vision he was
just having in that vision he was flying
around with a sword while there were
titans around him which could be
foreshadowing to this current situation
where you have people flying around with
swords and obviously the warriors and
their titans are in the battle as well
other foreshadowing comes from the fact
that his pure titan arguably looked like
a baby bird and now his shifter is
simply the evolved version of that
anyhow after seeing this development
flog gets tired of playing games and he
makes a beeline straight for the ship
like i said before all it takes is one
thunderspear to end this whole conflict
as the alliance won't be able to stop
the rumbling if the boat is destroyed
along the way he maneuvers past falco
pushes back hanji and uses one of his
two thunderspears on peak meaning he had
just one final shot to save eldir if he
could accurately fire this thunderspear
then parodies would have been saved
while the rest of the world would be
trampled but as he went to fire gabby
shot him in his other arm which
completely messed up the trajectory
the result was that both flock and his
thunderspear fell into the water and the
yagris had lost the one person who was
keeping them organized from that point
onwards the battle then basically became
a massacre with mikasa brutally
murdering her fellow islanders in the
most imaginative ways she could find
while this was happening onyankpon and
the mechanics had been loading the ship
with coal the entire time and with the
alliance now taking control of the port
the ship was finally ready to leave
there was of course a brief moment at
the end where falco began to lose
control of his titan but generally
speaking this wasn't that strange we saw
with aaron how certain people can go
berserk when using their titans for the
first time and pique vaguely warned
falco that his first transformation
wouldn't go well
thankfully before things could escalate
magus shut up to slice him out of there
and with that the main part of the war
was officially over all that was left
was to tie up some loose ends and this
is why the general stayed behind on the
island while everyone else got on board
the ship
over the years paradise has captured
various warships belonging to the malia
navy and mcgath knew that this cruiser
had the potential to catch up with the
alliance
this was a chance that mcgath
understandably wasn't willing to take so
much so that he was fully prepared to
die so that the rest of the alliance
could maintain their pursuit of eren
now regarding instructor shardis he
swoops in to kill a couple of jaegers
that were pursuing mcgath and following
that they each decide to work together
in the story so far both of these men
have played similar roles as it was them
who trained this current generation of
titan shifters ackman's and royalty it
was because of their instruction that
many of the main cast turned out the way
they did but in this scene mcgath
doesn't seem proud of that
accomplishment we've seen glimpses of
this in the past two episodes but the
general feels guilty for ignoring his
conscience and for turning these
innocent children into brainwashed
warriors
in reality he would have been a lot
happier if they could have all lived
normal lives and in this memory of his
students you'll notice that half of them
are dead one of them betrayed marley and
three others have time limits on how
much longer they can live
meanwhile switching back to chardis we
saw how a day earlier he didn't have the
spirit to fight back against the igress
as it was his belief that they'd gained
the support of people across the island
that said while he was in the fort he
witnessed his former students heading
south towards the harbour and once he
saw annie was with them he realized what
they were planning for them to be able
to put aside their differences for the
future of humanity it just showed how
much they'd grown and it inspired
shadows so much that he chose to take
action
what's sad about this though is that i'm
not entirely sure anyone on the ship
knew what keith did for them because he
didn't really announce himself until way
after they set sail regardless it's
obvious that he wasn't doing this for
the recognition and as mcgath finishes
laying out the gunpowder the general
then ignites it blowing up the cruiser
and everyone on board
this moment here was done really well
not just because of the music choice but
also because of gabby's tearful reaction
from what we've seen mcgath displayed
more empathy towards her than would ever
be expected from amalian and i think she
was grateful to him for this similar to
how she was grateful to that god who was
killed earlier in the season
moving on to the post-credits scene this
moment happens hours later when annie's
healed from her injuries and she's told
by the commander that they won't be
going to liberia as i mentioned earlier
the female titan wasn't aware that
saving liberia was impossible but after
hearing the news she collapses to her
knees as she's now lost her will to keep
fighting her promise to her dad was the
only thing giving her the motivation to
keep moving on but with that promise now
dead she barely has anything to live for
hanji goes on to explain however that
mcgath didn't sacrifice himself just for
the sake of mali or liberio but rather
it was to save as many unknown innocent
people as they could in that way the
command is trying to convince annie that
stopping the rumbling is a cause worth
fighting for even if her father can't be
saved
in response annie returns to the
original question she asked around the
campfire which is whether mikasa or any
of the scouts are prepared to kill aaron
if they're not prepared for aaron to die
then it will lead to a civil war between
both sides of the alliance and
considering where annie is mentally
right now she doesn't have the
conviction to fight with them or even
fight with aaron himself
the episode then ends with an aerial
shot of the ship as it makes his way
towards the hangar and the question of
whether the scouts are prepared to kill
aaron still remains unanswered
anyway people that was my breakdown for
episode 27 of attack on titan season 4
and remember the season finale won't be
coming out until the 3rd of april be
sure to sub so you don't miss my review
of that final episode and i'll also be
doing an update video if they announce a
part 3 for the final season
until the next one peace out